une verrue à Vouvray des dizaines de
voitures viennent donc que d'être
évacués d'un terrain privé évacuation
sous la supervision des gendarmes il
s'agit d'une décharge géante illégale
qui existait depuis 2015 le reportage de
Faustine
l'endroit a déjà été bien déblayé
puisqu'il y a quelques jours encore
jusqu'à 50 voitures envahissaient ce
terrain privé une décharge illégales à
ciel ouvert source de problèmes que la
mairie souhaitait voir disparaître
depuis plusieurs années déjà le danger
visuel parce que pour l'entrée de
Vouvray c'est vraiment
désagréable et la pollution des sols
puisque voilà on est en bord en bord de
Loire zone inondable je pense qu'il y
avait toutes les huiles de véhicules
tout ce qu'on peut trouver dans dans une
voiture quoi qui peut polluer puis des
poubelles des frigos mais impossible
d'intervenir sans décision de justice
c'est la découverte par les forces de
l'ordre d'un container où se trouvait
des voitures volées qui apprécient
l'évacuation le propriétaire qui ne vit
pas près de son terrain et entreposait
quelques véhicules personnels mais ce
serait laissé déborder par les dépôts
sauvages d'autres personnes les gens
pensent que c'est une décharge sauvage
c'est facile et accessible et c'est un
petit peu caché donc il pose tout et
n'importe quoi jusqu'à que ça devient ça
j'ai déjà déblayé une fois ou deux et
puis tout en le faisant doucement avec
ma petite énergie j'ai été vite débordée
j'ai eu des gros problèmes de santé donc
c'est encore pire et ça a pris cette
ampleur là et aujourd'hui je suis
soulagé qu'ils aient quand même réglé ce
problème en partie avec moi quoi le
propriétaire envisage de sécuriser
l'entrée du terrain quant à la mairie
elle espère maintenant l'intervention
des forces de l'ordre pour une autre
décharge sur un terrain privé en bord de
[Applaudissements]